[Music]
Paris and Prince Jackson step out in
honor of what would have been their late
father's 60th birthday for the Michael
Jackson diamond celebration at Mandalay
Bay Hotel in Las Vegas we honor our
father in different ways that might not
necessarily be completely public to them
but being here today is definitely an
awe-inspiring feeling because you know
our father was the King of Pop and he
did so much and I mean he is the king of
Pop you know but he did so much for the
music industry but I think he really put
emphasis and importance on the
charitable contributions to humanity
that he really used his platform to
voice and I think that this would have
been more this would make him proud er I
would assume then the musical
accomplishments that he has been able to
what does it mean to you to be here
it just means family and family to me as
a feeling and again with expectations we
honor him in our own way and I don't
really expect anyone else to understand
besides this dude right here and so I'm
just hope to be with him and my cousin
Austin is here too and like it's just
it's love
[Music]
[Applause]